everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we are in round 2
of the 2016 Sinquefield cup our
competitors today both drew in round
once they are going to be looking for a
victory today why it's gonna be played
by the Frenchman MVL he is the second
ranked player in the world only behind
Magnus Carlsen he's been on its hair the
past few years an exciting player to
watch his opponent playing the black
pieces vision on fan favor currently the
8th ranked player in the world but he
always comes really prepared for these
tournaments so I'm anxious to see how he
plays in this particular game we do have
an exciting one today starts out with
pawn to e4 pawn c6 and Knights f3 pawn
d5 Knight c3 so getting into the 2-night
variation in the cattle con then knight
f6 pawn ephod now this particular
variation Bobby Fischer used to play a
long time ago when he was younger didn't
really play it as he moved up in the
race and we don't see this very often so
if nothing else we have a doozy on our
hands because we just don't see this
very variation that often and so we
don't talk about it very often Knight to
e4 and then we have some secret tech
coming out if only the fifth move MBL
decides to play Knight to e2 kind of a
head-scratcher when I saw it I usually
don't see this particular play I'm not
sure what he's worried about if he just
has a particular reason that he likes to
play this but usually you might see
Bishop to e2 getting ready to castle on
the kingside you're not too worried
about your opponent taking your knight
you can always just respond take back
here having double pawns here on the C
file with Pawnee on b2 that's completely
fine opens up the door for the dark
square Bishop Queen to get involved into
the game so I'm not just too worried
about what he's afraid of he definitely
doesn't want to take here because now
after the pottery captures the knight on
f3 it's just kind of weird having the
pawn all up in your business but he
decides to go ahead and do some secret
tech 92 and then queen down to b6 now
this setting is up for the potential
quickest mate I've seen and high-level
play in a long time Queen down here to
f2 would be checkmate obviously we're
not gonna see that today these players
way too skilled for that pawn to d4
really the only way to stop this that
makes
any sort of sense but this also
solidifies his pawn on e5 pawn to e6
just fishing on solidifying his own pawn
chain and then Knight back here to g1
another one of those head scratchers
where I didn't expect him to play Knight
to f3 and then right back here to do one
a little bit later
Knight to g3 maybe for say I know it
doesn't like this night here on e4 but
Knight to g3 kind of forcing this move
if he takes okay that's gonna be
completely fine recapture with his own
pawn he's not in too bad a shape but
decides to play Knight to G 1 and then
pawn to f6 we do see pawn f3 forcing the
knight back to g5 capture here on f6
after the recapture pawn F to F for
forcing the knight to move but we all
kind of just know where it's gonna go
it's gonna go right back where it was
before
nice little outpost for the night here
on e4 MVL decides to now start to attack
this night here on e4 and doesn't like
it being there so he plays Knight to g3
which I thought he could have played
earlier Bishop to d7 just continuing
development for vision on after the
capture here on e4 then Bishop to c3
solidifying the pawn chain also
solidifies the square here on before
doesn't want the bishop to come down
here before with tempo checking the King
so place pawn here to c3 and the knight
here to a6 but all of a sudden Black has
a lead in development all the major
minor pieces are in the first rank for
white don't see that very often when
were thirteen moves into the game on it
on the opponent's side wishing on doing
a pretty good job now I can't castle on
the Kings side White's definitely blown
that plan up but he could always castle
on the Queen side if he wants to if he's
given that option his Knight really
couldn't come to c6 or d7 like he would
want to but later on he can easily get
this Titan bulbs of the game after pawn
to c5 he can have an exchange and then
bring us that over here to c5 nice
little central square would also defend
the square here on e4 so it definitely
has some options fishing on right now
with a slight advantage just from the
development standpoint now Queen set h5
making sure that his opponent does not
castle so that's the route that he
decides to go for King to d8 no
other option Bishop to c4 just getting
more pieces involvement of the actions
recognizing that he was behind in
development King to c7 opening up the
door for the rook to get involved since
he can't castle it's kind of the only
way upon set a four he notices his
opponent has a king here on c7 he's
gonna be on the Queen side for a while
so he starts to push forward on the
Queen side later on he can castle on the
Kings side have some safety but he wants
to go ahead and start attacking on the
Queen side since he does see some
weakness here pawn here to c5 partly
stopping the attack from the Queen
coming over here after once two also
wants to just break up some of the
synergy that White has with his pawn
structure Knight to e2 getting ready to
castle on the King side rook to d8
just a little bit protection on the
semi-open file once he has a discovered
attack with the bishop I wants to make
sure that if this palm were to capture
that he does have more attackers on this
D file a Bishop to e3 and all of a
sudden MBL's them a good job he was
behind in development just a few moves
ago he's kind of stopped any sort of
attack that bishi and on could have had
his opponent does have a exposed king
right now so all-in-all MBL's fought
back and I'd say right now it's about
even on board this Shannon continues
with pawn to f5 solidifying his pawn
chain also stopping the Queen from
getting over to the Queen side
especially attacking the square here on
c5 anytime you can block off your
opponent's a most important piece their
queen for more all the action is which
is on the Queen side the board
definitely take that opportunity to do
that castle on the King side came back
here to be 8 and then Queen up here to
f7 so it's starting to get a little bit
aggressive on board Knight back here to
c7 it's pretty bad
there is a poison pawn here a lot of
times why didn't you just come down and
take this material but if he takes all
of a sudden we're gonna see rook over
here to be won in this Queen is going to
fall so that's gonna be bad that's why
we don't see that on board Knight to c7
is the move a pawn up here to a5 just
starting to attack pushing on the Queen
side as we talked about MBL has a very
specific plan his queen
here on f7 is really just causing havoc
on the King side and then on the Queen
side he's just gonna be looking to push
his pawns get his bishops in the center
of the board really putting pressure get
his other rook involved and just try to
choke his opponent on the Queen side
first we see Queen to c6 Queen here to
f6 attacking the rook first we see the
Bishop down here to d6 kind of a
discovered defense with the rook here on
d8 defending that rook there on h8 pawn
takes on c5 we see the bishop recapture
and that appeared to d4 kind of clogging
things up a little bit
Queen to d6 pawn up here - before you
start to see a lot of pressure around
this e six squared we have the Queen we
had the bishop we have the knight attack
in his pawn we have the knight the
bishop and the Queen all around the
square here on c6 so both sides they're
gonna really be looking to hold on to
this you could see some later moves a
roof over here to e8 trying to hold down
that material but keep an eye on that
east six square Queen back here to e7
say okay I'm gonna go and take your
queen if you want to take my bishop
we're obviously not gonna see that from
mvl brings his queen back here to h6 and
so the bishop comes back here to d6 so
alleviating some of that pressure that
white had right away and then rook over
here to d1 an open file both sides
really trying to control that opened
e-file rook here to f8 controlling this
F file for a little while Bishop back
here to f2 if he wants to he can bring
his Bishop to h4 pinning down the Queen
to the rook one of those pieces is going
to fall so that's kind of where White's
thinking right now
a Brooke here to f7 or f6 excuse me
forces this Queen to move the Queen
comes back here to h4 I almost think it
would be better to play Queen to h3 if
this rook ever moves it's gonna be a
discovered attack on the Queen the
bishop pretty much has to be here on f2
to protect that so all in all I think
the Queen back here to h3 is a little
bit safer it's still attacking the
square here on
seven and there's no real benefit from
it being here on h4 but in the game
decides to play Queen to h4 and the
night down here to d5 now the next move
is pretty interesting from MVL he
decides to go kind of bonkers and go for
some pretty crazy exchanges on board he
sees his pawn here on e6 which we've
been talking about for a while and he
decides now's the time to go and start
attacking it with his knight takes here
on e6 I think he probably just taken
here I'm d5 that makes sense after the
pawn recaptures Queen back here to age 3
I think he's gonna be safe here but
instead I think he's just been eyeing
that Square for a while so he says now's
the time takes on e6 Bishop captures
Bishop takes here on d5 now the pawn
kind of an in-between move down here to
e3 almost forcing this a little bit
Bishop takes on e3 Bishop takes on d5
Bishop over here to a7 check King takes
on a 7 but then the Queen comes down
here to f2 and I'm not sure if MBL did
not recognize this next move and it's
just Bishop to c5 nice little decoy move
kind of forcing the Queen to come here
after the Queen recaptures then all of a
sudden rook to d7 so let's let's take a
step back and look at this all of a
sudden MBL gave a lot of exchanges on
Bors and at the end of the day they're
equal and material but fishing on has a
bishop to the three extra ponds that MBL
has getting into the late game you
always want those pieces on board you
can just do so much pawns
if you're up and material it's one thing
but if your parent has more pieces they
can just apply too much pressure gobble
up those pawns and all of a sudden any
sort of advantage or you know equal
position that you have just goes out the
window so vision on getting into the
endgame with a much better position in
VL starts with rook to e1 pawn age 6
King to f2 came back here to b8 one of
those questionable moves for me the
Queen's are off the board which means
getting your Kings involved into the
action is very very important so King to
a6 makes a ton of sense it doesn't have
to wear
Bishop's attacking or anything too crazy
if his rooks get involved into the game
that's that's completely fine but you
know he could always just bring his
bishop to protect it a little bit if he
wanted to King to b8 definitely had my
head scratching a little bit pawn to c4
but she comes back here to c6 rook takes
Bishop takes here on d7 so exchanging
material the board I think just even
increases the lead that vision on has on
this board a rook over here to b1 rook
a6 rook up here to b6
Moschino not looking to trade that off
he wants to have a rook on board so rook
takes here on a5 I'll work over here to
h6
rook c5 so we're just seeing tons of
exchanges all over the board
pawn up H to h4 then rook to c4 pawn to
g3 King c7 pawn to h5 and then after
pawn to b5 in this position we actually
saw mvo resign there's no way for him to
actually stop the push from this beep on
a lot of times I'll get asked from
players to just continue on the
variation of how it could have gone if
there was another resignation so if we
look at it we could see rook to a6 and
then start pushing both sides start
pushing on the board
pawn to h7 but the the tricky part right
here is the rook down here to see two
now we'd really like to just play King
to g1 he doesn't want his phone to play
rook over here to h2 because he could
just gobble up that pond right here but
he can't play g1 I can't play F when he
can't play a 1 because all of a sudden
pawn to b2 and we're gonna see checkmate
on the next move it doesn't matter if
the pawn comes up here to h8 and gets a
queen it's going to be checkmate now if
we come back and say let's have the King
go to e3 then all of a sudden the rook
can just come over here to h2 gobble up
this material there's just not enough on
board for white to really do so he
decided to go ahead and read
I do wish a lot of players even in the
position that we looked at on board
would continue a little bit more just
for the fans since a lot of times we'll
look at this position say I just don't
know sure you're behind a little bit but
why give up definitely wish you would
have gone a little bit more but MVL my
guess is he was just stressed out it was
probably the craziest game we've seen in
a while a variation that neither player
is playing all too often there was
definitely some secret tech that had
them going in many different ratios I
don't think they expected to go to in
this particular game so although NBL had
had enough he recognized vishing I was
going to witness a vision on getting the
victory congratulations to him so he
moves up to the top of the standings NBL
on the other hand with just a draw and a
loss will be looking to continue being
the secondary player in the world but he
has a uphill climb so hopefully you guys
enjoyed round 2 definite an exciting
match and I'll see you in round 3 thanks
for watching